it's like a [ __ ] sign up you won't
burp it up it's gonna burp it your nose
here oh [ __ ] hey what's going on
everybody for first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones the
show with hot questions and even hotter
wings it's a very special day we have an
inner pole wu-tang clan sort of tag team
going on Rison's here Paul banks is here
together they make banks and steals and
the album anything but words is due out
August 26th guys welcome to the show and
Paul from what I understand you're a fan
of hot ones or at least peripherally
aware of what's going on yeah I've seen
a couple I saw the DJ Khalid one it's
like if they didn't tell him enough
before he got here what was happening by
like the third wing looking off camera
like fuck-ass [ __ ] is this unless my
heart is on fire what you call a victory
and she ain't no victory me my brother
yesterday I doing number me because of
problem and RZA you seem like you're
kind of in the khaled seat and that I
know Paul I think talked you into doing
this show he definitely talked me into
doing it so first of all respects your
show I mean I'm glad you're gonna show
that elite City you know you're the
first vegan we've ever had on the show
okay on the first vegan and what we got
here
we have vegan nuggets so these are all
animal free milk I know that you guys
are really mess with milk but the milk
is almond milk Paul cuz you're a fan of
the show you have conventional wings and
then what I've done is I've alternated
so that nobody can call foul play
five wings altogether is it ten ways so
we have twice the talent we go half as
many only half as much food you blew it
phonebook oh man I thought I was getting
10 wings well why don't you see if you
can make it through five I'll see that
and then afterwards we'll give you it to
go back
[Music]
so the first one sriracha that's no big
deal I don't even know sriracha
qualified has a hot sauce Paul I'm not
gonna already only in that dump so I'm
sure this comes up in almost every
interview but uh how'd you guys end up
coming together I hear that RZA your
manager asked you who would you like to
collaborate with and the name that
popped into your head was Paul
we had a have some tequila together and
hit the club and we became cool playing
chess with each other
this had a cool energy that I felt
comfortable with as a person I mean it's
a pole as you know rocked the New York
indie scene for some time now a nadie
hung with Paul so I was like y'all you
know gotta bring me 50 people because
you know I like Paul see if he's
interested in walking with me or is
people reached out to me because I did
an interview promoting my first solo
record and I cited Rizzo's and influence
and I think I said I actually like him
Jack to beat which I didn't really do
but you know I was kind of speaking on
the fact that this is a big influence on
me and so his manager hit me up and said
you know do you want to meet and that's
what led us to the tequila bar and then
we started playing chess and then we
started jamming yeah well you know
there's that like those booting there's
the stick as a stick it's like a
popsicle stick in the middle of this
looks good man
this is actually our hot sauce very
proud of this one I think it's the best
hot sauce ever made but I'll kind of
leave that up to you am i underdressed
here or does that look I want to see
something happen here see fire come out
the bottle it's not that hot a sauce I
love Chipotle I'll be the gun not the
restaurant I mean the chili chili
actually those good sausage like fruity
thank you yes sir your mouth kind of
lights up a little bit but it's a sweet
tasting sauce yeah that was the move
that was bunk long yo that was nothing
like did I mean about nothing as and it
taste is good it is I'm worried about
the y'all say the Calabrian off the show
you did you know me so heal each other
he was like hypervenom so he was like
you know me I don't want to run off the
show but I'm ready
carefully he was good Thank You Man
so we're too but we're really like three
or four or five in so right the five
intensity of imam reza from the outside
looking in understanding the whole
wu-tang family tree is a little
complicated
everybody knows the core the guys in 36
chambers but then sometimes I'll just be
walking through Times Square but some
guy I'll slam a mixtape into my chest
and claim that he's mu Tang affiliated
so can you break this down for me once
and for all
what do you need to do to become family
wow I think we got enough time but I'll
give you a little bit of it so I don't
hold I don't know I don't know give you
that next tape is one dude used to walk
around my hand with a big wooden wool
Tang logo one I mean he used to walk
you'll see him like way down the block
he's big dude - lady six for coming
through boom boom boom and then you know
he'll get up to you he had the fangs
everything like good up Abid
do you guys ever talk about that because
it's a little weird to have all these
cells jump up all over the place that's
maybe on some level you gotta be worried
about a devaluing of the brand or
something look I would I mean he's
talking I'm all I'm always honest or not
- yeah yeah so I have a good friend of
mine that works in law enforcement and
they told me when you go you get
arrested
it says blood Crips will take it really
that's a box you can check I look at it
as the fans that's family B to be real
with you and I think they reciprocate
that back by being like yo on whoo man I
had a fans tell me I couldn't do what I
wanted to do like you can't do that a
bit like me I can't do you telling me
what I can do yet they have a whole
codebook yeah I'm the wolf
that's where the game is gonna change in
a way that's dramatic and severe it's
just going it's exponential at this
point pain 101 seven or eight right now
so this is seven yeah it's already
burning is hot man it's automatic bone
right doesn't it just tastes like hot
metal face is gone you're obsessed with
chess Paul you're a surfer these are
both disciplines that are mind over
matter what sorts of things are you
drawing on now that the hot sauce is
starting to hit right now okay much test
is like a sword fight you must think
folks before you move think I'm thinking
about that that fourth wing about that
Oh see my tongue is now starting they're
like light up of the air talking like
I'm like like a Nutty Professor or Dumb
and Dumber when you lift the bar and the
song got stuck it's starting to oh man
yeah
I'm the situs inversus way like five
minutes is there surf experience helping
you out at all
are you drawing on anything right now
serenity now kind of way yes balance I
put myself out in the ocean just yeah
wait not a wave calm enjoy myself what
do you guys play chess room wins more
often this guy if wanna if we're on a
clock like a short clock I got a chance
but uh long games not so far
chess I think it's also kind of like a
reflection of your emotions like a
baguette I got a log you at home a lot
but if I get to even hope like a little
disc want to things at home with the
words I noticed that I lose my piece I
lose my queen on the board and I play
hard though like I could win without the
Queen something can go on in your life
yeah it affects me it affects a single
piece on the board yeah I noticed that
about me that's the universe is an
outrageous place huh there's albums just
I like that yeah it's gonna teach over
there all right so this is mad dog 357
used to be our hottest way now it's our
second hottest Wayne because we're just
constantly up in the anteater mount
woods so we count to three and go I want
to detect that you're eating a part of
it the head sauce on that matter me to
come on is say you might sec me okay I'm
ready I mean that it's so nasty right
yes like this tofu darkness this sucks
is that now you sit on the end up eating
the rubber that's a bubble wing well
that's just hard ain't it yeah my ball
sock
you guys are both movie buffs hmm you
have directing acting experience legit
straight up I know that you're a movie
buff - yep
I wonder who would you want to play you
in a movie and what would the opening
scene be I really don't know who played
me in a movie but some guy in Game of
Thrones it looks like me I don't know
why you're talking but come up to me all
the time now see how they bloodshot or
what no II just you want it get in there
is in there I'm parking that's what
happens man the hot ones effect I keep
your tongue in the milk Louie don't you
got like a like a X plane I can't talk
that much but like uh that's the fun
that's the fun I'll just talk with the
bone uh-huh okay that's deaf the next
one's dead would that mean well exactly
what it says as Paul knows it's sort of
a tradition on the last wing to dab it
there's plenty on there look at them
it's a lot on there is a you dab well
this Matt dad when you put it on the the
what kind of vegan a vegan nugget
whatever you call it right it's soaks in
I knew this would happen which is why I
mixed in the Nuggets I knew that whoever
okay did another pocket morning it's not
absorbing more sauce than the other ones
no this bag I thought on the contrary I
think the chicken ones are more hot
that's my team Oh hence why I'm off on
so if you look fine so all right so I
put a dab on this that might put it to
rest
you tend added that'll make you feel
like I'm dumb dumb swimming yeah that
you're dealing with the same things I'm
you know you brought me here just my
will I think you should damn I'm gonna
damn it I want to daba daba Doo
what did you say to persuade RZA I said
it was funny and it was a good show and
I'm working on my Carmen hungry if I
wasn't working on my comedy you'd say
nah yeah I don't think that you're
losing it now that you're this deep are
you happy you came
you know what we're having a good time
this is a unique experience for me we
tried to extend for you you know what I
mean which was I'm appreciating the love
here the great people at the table are
you gonna eat the bite with the dab on
it I'm gonna do what you do all right oh
oh you want to dab you down I mean after
the UM after this I'm just gonna be
swimming it so funny when you walk out
cut the camera I'll be out of here yeah
change Halloween I don't do it first cuz
I don't take the bite yeah Oh like I'm
trying to like I'm last I'm doing it but
I'm last but you're doing it because you
also get a little nauseous when these
these are these hopefully things go do
they get bigger and your stomach bubble
a little bit open up in there mr. gross
okay I want to move it around a little
bit okay barefoot that finger make sure
you after this you're thoroughly wash
mine I'll just use the stick there you
go have its Nick Cannon oh yeah it tough
to ask a question but it's gonna be hard
for you guys to answer and that's just
the show yeah we are [ __ ] with
Megadeth liquid rage with liquid rage
pit into it it says fill alive cheers
cheers Cheers
[Music]
are you at your job right oh my god you
killed it your job Paul I put my inside
here you know ah in a good way
I don't know I'm glad I dabbed on that
last right I can handle that [ __ ] man -
easy there okay it's like a [ __ ] shot
of liquor that you won't burp it up it's
gonna burp through your nose here oh
[ __ ] sorry for a business-minded viewers
okay be some aspiring artists themselves
you guys have been in a long time you
know about greedy executives you know
about backstabbers know about the snakes
in the grass
yeah do you have any advice for those
viewers on how to keep an eye on those
people to make sure that they don't get
the best okay I mean get a good lawyer I
think as an artist maybe you can be a
little bit naive and I think that you
got to remember the other half of the
equation is often like
people and they kind of they're like
thinking numbers and they're not
thinking about your craft or how close
it is to your heart or the integrity of
our to any of that money you can get
fooled assuming that people are more
invested in your you know your art than
they are and in fact you're you're just
like a number and that can be alienating
and kind of take a lot of the fun out of
the business and I think people get
burned by that just realize that they're
kind of [ __ ] with wolves rather than
sort of fellow artists so I think you
got to keep that in mind but that that's
just the game there's not you know you
don't really need to change it you just
need to be ready to understand that like
there's the art side of the equation
then there's the business side of the
equation don't waste your time worrying
about the business side of things art is
something that grows better out there
you know um art is something that grows
over time I've been a lot of artists
because now I come from a successful era
in the music industry with thousand make
millions of dollars and that has changed
and therefore some artists made into the
game doing it for that million dollar
move not realizing that the art they're
creating is like Picasso never know when
it's going to become valuable if the
money is what's making you do it you're
gonna have a problem do it I got to a
point in the business was I wouldn't
even go in the studio less it was a
check involved you know I mean but
before I was making money you couldn't
pull me out of a studio so I've luckily
had it long enough career to be turned
back to that and I think jay-z is a
great example of this for hip hoppers he
kept moving forward and then when he
looks back
it's like he's he moves home for days up
on the mountain guys you made it through
it's worth acknowledging RZA almost
completely unaffected in a way that's
pretty amazing
oh no man we're talking about oh you
talked him into it Paul what you're
expecting tougher than You're Expecting
not as bad as you expect little tougher
little tougher than yours
newfound respect for some of the guys
who have made it through it's real it's
real and nine especially is real don't
take that off the off the show I want to
see all the people deal with that you
can scream from the mountain because you
made it all the way through guys the
floor is yours that camera that camera
thirty seconds let people know what you
guys got going on in your lives banks
the steals anything but words out August
26 check it out one more time I don't
know man I'm that's it
somebody bring me in town the new head
the new song which we are we're pretty
proud of called jarring which is out now
yes out now the reason I point that song
out the giant is a song that's about the
underdog when you see David and Goliath
people think that Goliath was the giant
no David was to China and that's where
we're going into the world and it's kind
of like us today Hwang's zero exactly
there's a Paul Shawn five bump bump
thanks bro
thanks for coming in